you does anybody know who this guy is
who is this guy come on it ain't me for
sure cause I'm not white but who is this
guy
who
Warren Buffett it is good for you
this is Warren Buffett that's his net
worth in 1957.
how many guys have more money than 140
000 reason if you got more than 140 000
net worth okay you're richer than Warren
Buffett once was
now watch this we're about to dissect
this and then you'll see where I'm going
with this and I'm going to give you
clear leaks some of you are making and
to make sure you plug it so it doesn't
get worse for you and you Excel and one
day we're telling your story on stage
like this
1957
he's worth 140. 13 years later
1970.
he's worth 25 million
what do you want to be worth in 13 years
huh
long term you want to think that long
too long right oh 13 years
you ready for the next one the next
one's intense by the way
from 1970 to 1983. what do you think his
net worth is in 83
620.
from 6 20 to 1996 you ready
boom
17 billion
2009
37 billion
2022
97 billion
from 140 000 dollars
200 billion dollar net worth why though
why what do you think separates him from
his peers
I'm reading uh they write this book down
guys everybody needs to go write this
book I don't write it's a book called
The how to invest by a guy named David
Rubinstein that's worth four billion
dollars okay he's the guy that started a
company called Carlisle Group you
probably heard of Carlisle group he goes
in interviewing all of these
billionaires and guys that are running
hedge funds and ask them what is your
investment strategy right do you know 90
of all the people you'll see when you
read this I'd say 70 of all the people
they Enter he interviewed everybody
gives credit to one person guess who it
is
this guy and guess what they say about
him
his Edge on everybody was what he said
what
and everybody else is thinking what
my return this year is like no man we're
going to go long term do you guys know a
year and a half ago what they were
bashing uh Buffett for
Warren Buffett sitting on 125 billion
dollars of cash with Berkshire Hathaway
we feel Warren buff has lost his ways
you know he is no longer the same Warren
Buffett he once used to be the last
seven years he's been losing to SMP you
are better off to put the money in the S
P 500 or Bitcoin or ethereum rather than
putting the money with Berkshire
Hathaway
how many guys would love to have 125
billion dollars of cash today
what do you think he's about to buy
he's going shopping
and guess what he's buying the next
three six 12 months companies on
Flipping sale
and the next thing you know boom Next
Level now
the guy is not going to live another 26
years to see a couple more doubles I
think he's 90 years old right now but
the point is this what if what if many
of us think like he does
what if many of us think like he does
so again those who capitalize from the
current times will be let me tell you
we'll be long-term thinkers
will be long-term thinkers
here lies a short-term thinker
over the next three six 12 months I'm
telling you right now go to the cemetery
of former money makers filled with
short-term thinkers everywhere
when I study for my series seven I
studied for my Series 7 every day next
to my grandmother's plot at Forest Lawn
right after 17134 freeway I don't know
if you guys know where that's at
and I would sit right next to her and I
would read my Capital book to take my
series seven because she had just died
so I would study there it was calming
for me
when I would take a break I would walk
and this was my exercise
yeah I don't recognize that name
nope
39 years this person lived
62 years
83 years
49 years and you'd stand like this who
was this guy
and it was like one big one you see this
name and you go Google it oh wow this
guy was somebody
okay crazy boom
and I would sit down and say okay when
the day comes and you die what are you
going to say when they walk by your plot
here lies a short-term thinker hell to
the no
how many guys want to say that with me
on three one two three
[Applause]
say it with me say I'm a long-term
thinker
say it again
say it louder
even louder
last time
don't say it to yourself regularly
if your wife is upset say babe remember
babe we're what what babe we're
long-term thinkers we are long-term
thinkers you're gonna see stress is
going to go like this confidence is
going to go like this
Poise is going to go here
so now let's look at the whole thing
together because I want to make a point
to you guys I want to make a point to
you guys
everything I just showed you this is a
snapshot
they have on one page
it shows thou where it was to where it's
at today
interest rates how many times it changed
home price value how many times it
changed but this is the one I want to
show you
look at the amount of times Warren
Buffett
increased his net worth and how many
doubles it was look at this
from 40 from 140 foul to 25 million you
know what that is that's 178 X
178 X
the next one is 25x from 25 million to
620.
how many guys would like to increase
your net worth 25x the next 13 years
would anybody like that
that's exactly the point
so now next one
27x from 620 to 17 billion then it's 2.2
x
then it's 2.68 the guy was struggling at
the end he only went from 37 billion to
100 billion poor guy if you guys want to
send him some money you can sell them
five bucks I'm sure he'll appreciate if
you send him some money
but he started with 140.
what's the number you're starting off
with so what's the difference between
this guy and you well Pat you can't
compare me to Buffett I get it I'm not
telling you for you to be worth 100
billion dollars however many years from
now
but can you think long term to say 40
years from now I want to be worth 100
million is that realistic of course it
is why can't you put 100 million dollar
number to yourself
why can't you say hey you know what babe
I don't know 13 years I want to be worth
10 million
let's solve for 10 million in 13 years I
lost a lot of money to us today when we
got 52 000 but if this guy can go from
52 to 20 from 140 to 125 I want to go 52
to 10 million in 13 years great then go
solve for that
and it gives you something to look
forward to and it's exciting when you're
thinking that way
next one
as we go through this okay
as we go through this
I want to show you this
if thou from 1983
went from 1258 to 28 down how many times
is that
does anybody how many times that is that
is 23x
let's take 23x and see where Dao will be
from today by 2061. many of you will be
alive in 2061. believe it or not we're
living a long life nowadays
here's what it looks like
that was going to be at 655 902
.
you know what this means long-term
future looks what
short-term future short term times look
what maybe scary but not long term so
now in order for this to work for you
you need a clear Philosophy for this to
happen
[Music]